[Music]
on this wednesday night the mission to
stop moscow the west tries to stay one
step ahead of putin nato and the eu are
now more resolved
and united
than ever and braces for millions more
ukrainian refugees personal revelations
and damning accusations the claims
against the former head of canada's
largest union
deadly tornado
the new disaster in new orleans and
public health restrictions are vanishing
but for how long we sort of have one
foot on the safe side and one foot on
the threatened side the problem of being
in a covet holding pattern
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jackson proskow
hi there and thanks for joining us the
next 48 hours could be critical in the
battle for ukraine world leaders are
holding a series of high-stakes meetings
in europe focused on countering russia
nato secretary general is worried and
increasingly desperate vladimir putin
may use chemical weapons the alliance is
deploying four new battle groups to its
eastern flank as extra deterrence and
for the first time the u.s has formally
declared that russia has committed war
crimes in ukraine
we have all seen really horrific
images and accounts
from the extensive and unrelenting
attacks on civilians and civilian sites
being conducted by russian forces in
ukraine
as the war enters its second month nato
believes 40 000 russian troops have been
killed wounded or taken prisoner as
redmond shannon reports that has not
stopped the relentless assault on
civilians
escaping from what's been described as
hell on earth more than 300 buses and
cars finished their long journey out of
besieged and bombed mariupol
traumatized cold and hungry new
satellite images wednesday show the
devastation of mariupol from above where
tens of thousands of people remain
trapped
ukraine's deputy prime minister says
there is a new agreement with russia to
set up nine humanitarian corridors
although previous deals have fallen
apart almost immediately many of the
millions of displaced people still
inside ukraine hope to make it out of
the country 3.5 million have already
done so
the european union announcing new
measures to share the enormous burden
across the continent we have established
a solidarity platform where member
states exchange their capacities their
problems their challenges and help each
other
the day before he addresses nato leaders
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
speaks to two more parliaments
pressing buttons by talking about
liberty to french lawmakers
and the nuclear threat at the occupied
chernobyl site with politicians in japan
the only other country to experience a
nuclear disaster on the same scale he
urged both nations to ramp up sanctions
as russia releases new footage of a key
airstrike that killed eight people this
week the capital's mayor vitaly
klitschko gave an update on his city's
death toll from 264
civilians
was four children
loading some reported gains made by
ukrainian forces in the area small city
macariff
and
almost
whole airplane
already in the control is ukrainian
soldier
moscow again insisted wednesday that it
does not target unarmed ukrainian
civilians something ukraine dismisses as
lies and the kremlin's spokesperson said
that his country reserves the right to
use nuclear weapons when it faces a
quote existential threat
jackson
redmond shannon in london thanks redmond
the war in ukraine has united the west
in a way not seen since the depths of
the cold war today prime minister justin
trudeau addressed the european
parliament where he spoke of the threat
russia poses to democracies everywhere
tomorrow trudeau will join nato leaders
to discuss military options and new
concerns in the region our david aiken
is traveling with the prime minister and
joins us now with the latest from
brussels david
well jackson justin trudeau spoke for
about 20 minutes his themes reinforcing
and supporting this remarkable european
unity in the face of russian aggression
putin thought we were divided
he thought he could weaken the eu and
nato
he miscalculated
and he is seeing it backfire
nato and the eu are now more resolved
and united
than ever trudeau was the only canadian
pm to ever address the 69 year old
european parliament he did it once
before in 2017 and in both speeches he
stressed canada's ties to the continent
canada
the eu
and all of our partners and allies
are facing a defining moment
we
cannot
fail we have felt that we can rely on
the people of canada and on canada when
it comes to defending freedom democracy
in europe but european leaders have a
new worry the potential deployment by
russia of chemical weapons against
ukraine that's a deployment nato warns
which would completely change the nature
of the conflict the spread
of chemical or biological agents used in
ukraine may have direct consequences
also for the population living in living
in nato other countries in europe so it
just
underscores the seriousness of
our concerns nato leaders are expected
to agree to provide ukraine with more
equipment to help protect its citizens
against a chemical biological even
nuclear attack
justin trudeau will be pressed to
explain how canada can help
jackson david aiken in brussels thank
you
nearly four million people have now fled
the war in ukraine and millions more are
displaced within that country the crisis
is straining resources of aid agencies
who were already grappling with a surge
in refugees from other larger conflicts
as heather urex west reports aid workers
are now fighting to make sure there's
enough help and attention for those
suffering no matter where they are
a deal alceri knows the pain and fear so
many ukrainians have experienced the
last few weeks
it's become his reality now for nearly
eight years we don't get to see our
families especially my kids haven't seen
my dad and mom
for about eight years now whenever my
mom calls me she tells me are we going
to see your kids before we die are we
going to see your kids before we die
al-siri lives with his children near
toronto
but his mom dad brother and sisters live
in santa the capital city of yemen where
war and famine mean their lives are
constantly under threat it's really
horrible and difficult especially when
we hear our friends here you know when
the family family dies because of this
war
and you know we just imagine when would
we get the news ourselves
the war in ukraine has triggered a
devastating humanitarian crisis but it
is by no means the largest in the world
while the united nations estimates 12
million people in ukraine require aid
more than 13 million people are in need
in syria afghanistan and yemen each have
a staggering 24 million people in crisis
that is a danger is that you know the
new shiny crisis is often where the
attention is directed and so then people
do shift their donations away from one
crisis to another
it's why the un and aid agencies are now
struggling to raise necessary supports a
virtual pledge event held last week for
assistance to yemen came up three
billion dollars short what kind of
choices
are humanitarians faced with when you're
not seeing the level of funding and the
level of support that's needed
they're very difficult choices
choices alceri can't bear to consider
though he understands the pain of so
many ukrainians it pains him to feel
that when it comes to his home country
the world has looked away
heather urex west global news washington
one of the world's most notable
advocates for diplomacy and peace
madeleine albright has died of cancer
she was a trailblazer and a luminary and
she was the first woman to serve as
secretary of state
she left an indelible
mark on the world and on the united
nations
after serving as the u.s ambassador to
the united nations albright was
america's top diplomat under president
bill clinton for four years
in 2012 she was awarded the medal of
freedom by president barack obama the
highest civilian honor in the u.s
albright fled the nazis in
czechoslovakia during world war ii as a
child and just last month in an op-ed
for the new york times she said if
russia invaded ukraine it would be a
quote historic error
albright was 84.
new trails of destruction in the
southern u.s
coming up the aftermath of a deadly
twister
plus the allegations facing the former
head of canada's largest union
this dark funnel cloud touched down in
new orleans claiming the life of at
least one person and injuring others it
devastated the area around 7 30 last
night flattening buildings and wiping
out power for thousands
one woman was killed as the storm moved
through texas and one man whose home was
leveled in new orleans was with his son
when the tornado hit
and the house started shaking and then
when it pulled the roof off it was
actually i had i was you know sheltering
him and then it was pulling me off the
ground and i pushed him down and and my
feet came off the ground a little bit
and then and then it was gone and then i
dropped
louisiana is sending in 300 national
guard troops to help in the aftermath of
the storm
canada's largest private sector union
says its former president accepted money
from a supplier for products he
allegedly promoted to employers of union
members unifor revealed the results of
its investigation into jerry diaz who
served as leader for nearly a decade
just after he announced his decision to
enter rehab
abigail beeman explains
they are not closing our damn plant
without one hell of a fight the
best-known face of canadian labor former
long-time head of unifor jerry dyess now
mired in scandal the investigation found
that diaz accepted money from a supplier
of covet 19 rapid test kits
that he had introduced to employers of
uniform members unifor alleges dyess
accepted 50 000 dollars from a test
supplier he allegedly gave half to a
colleague who filed a complaint dyess
released a statement shortly before
unifor revealed the details this past
december my life took a remarkable turn
for the worse when i was confronted with
a debilitating sciatic nerve issue it's
hard for me to say this but my coping
mechanism has been painkillers sleeping
pills and alcohol these factors have
impaired my judgment in recent months i
am entering a residential rehabilitation
facility
last month dice went on medical leave
then announced his retirement earlier
this month he did not respond to
interview requests from global news
unifor is canada's biggest public sector
union and represents some global news
employees the union says what happened
is an isolated incident asked whether
police will be investigating we have
sought outside council throughout this
process to guide us to obviously getting
an external investigator do the police
have enough to go ahead and implement
criminal charges and it's yet to be
determined but it would not surprise me
at this time because the amount is so
significant gaia stands charged with
violating unifor's code of ethics in his
statement he said he quote was always
guided by the principles set out in our
constitution the next step will be a
hearing but so far daya says he hasn't
participated in the investigation on his
doctor's advice abigail beeman global
news ottawa
as demand for electric vehicles takes
off canada's hard-hit auto sector is
surging to keep up a 5 billion ev
battery plant is coming to canada's
motor city windsor ontario and as mike
lay reports the investment will drive
thousands of green jobs and position the
country as a leader in the
transportation revolution
ontario's premier was positively giddy
in announcing a new gigafactory lg
energy solution
and automaker slantus are joining forces
to invest 5 billion
dollars those are big numbers put
another way it's the largest automotive
investment in canadian history for the
country's first lithium-ion electric
vehicle battery manufacturing plant it
also re-establishes windsor ontario as
canada's auto capital after years of
watching factories close and move to the
u.s and mexico
is it a shot in the arm is it a game
changer but i'll tell you windsorites
know that it is much much more than that
it's much more for canada as well the
market for battery sales is expected to
grow on average more than 20 percent per
year until 2030 into a 360 billion
dollar industry and while 80 percent of
the world's electric batteries are
produced in asia canada has long been
seen as having potential because of its
natural resources
canada is the only nation in the western
hemisphere with the capacity and the
materials to transform cobalt
graphite lithium and nickel into the
next generation of batteries that proved
too enticing for stellantis and lg to
pass up access to resources could save
them billions in supply chain expenses
and it's one of those rare cases where
environmental groups see an upside to
more mining operations i'm just very
aware of the trade-offs right we're in a
race to uh to avoid the worst impacts of
climate change and we've got to do that
by totally transforming our industries
transitioning to cleaner technologies
and those technologies have they require
mineral inputs and with this gigafactory
canada has staked its claim to being a
bigger player in the eevee game
microlight global news toronto
pandemic anxiety ahead why not everyone
is ready to lift coveted restrictions
just yet
moderna released new interim data today
showing its low-dose covid19 vaccine
works on children as young as six months
old the company says early results show
kids aged six months to six years
developed high levels of antibodies from
shots containing a quarter of the dose
given to adults
moderna plans to ask regulators to
authorize two small dose shots for kids
under six in the coming weeks if
approved the vaccine could start going
into arms this summer
after years of covet 19 mandates and
restrictions canadians are starting to
see a return to normal but as we take
off the masks and ditch vaccine
passports health officials warn another
covid surge could bring back public
health measures as jamie morocco
explains that state of flux can wreak
havoc on our mental health from a must
to no longer mandatory the decision to
wear a mask is becoming a personal
choice i really hope that everyone who
comes in the store respects
our feelings on the matter experts say
it's understandable why the latest
lifting of long-standing public health
measures has some feeling hesitant
really hoping we're coming out finally
and in an exhausted state as we do while
at the same time half expecting that
we're going to get pushed right back
into it again a possibility that's left
many stressed anxious and even depressed
social psychologist amy cuddy calls this
pandemic flux syndrome
we're in a prolonged liminal state and a
liminal state is where we sort of have
one foot on the safe side and one foot
on the threatened side and we're really
not sure
where to place our weight our search
capacity a collection of adaptive
systems that we use for survival in very
stressful situations is shot we've been
warned that restrictions could come back
at any time kovit hasn't disappeared and
in fact we're seeing a spike in omicron
cases globally we're even seeing that
here in canada in wastewater in alberta
and saskatchewan we almost expect these
numbers to increase a little because of
the release or you know relief from some
of the precautions despite this there
are calls to see the federal government
lift all remaining mandates and in the
u.s the white house is being lobbied to
remove one of its last
masks on planes i don't like the covid
it's dangerous but i'm tired of the mess
for many it will take more than removing
a mask to move on
for a fresh start cuddy says it may come
down to a conscious choice
we are very
psychologically resilient our
psychological immune systems are strong
and most of us will get through this and
return to our baseline level
taking the time we need to recalibrate
and adjust to our new normal jamie
morocco global news toronto
[Music]
he lived through the nazi occupation of
ukraine and survived the holocaust but
96 year old boris romanchenko could not
escape the newest war in europe as
russian troops advanced on the city of
harkeev romanchenko was killed by a
rocket that hit his apartment marking a
cruel end to a remarkable life
mike armstrong reports
it is in a word unfair
these are municipal workers in the town
of harkev ukraine their job on this day
to recover the remains of a 96 year old
man in his apartment
he was home friday when the building was
hit by shelling in a war started by
russia with an alleged mission to
denazify ukraine
russian troops killed a man who knew the
horrors of actual nazis
as a teenager during the second world
war boris romanchenko survived not one
concentration camp but three and forced
labor at a fourth camp
later in life he worked with a group
documenting nazi crimes
ukraine's president paid tribute to
romanchenko monday asking his country to
remember how many things romanchenko had
been through and survived
he was also remembered tuesday with a
moment of silence in the german
parliament
he
influenced countless
people throughout his life and he was
still doing it in uh good health for his
age
and so his life was a blessing
now at the time of the attack
romanchenko's neighbor was home as well
there was terrible shelling he says it
wasn't a bam more of a whistle three
terrible whistles
now the building may be uninhabitable
but some have no other options harkive
still faces russian shelling
this woman says she's alone and on a
pension there's nowhere else to go she's
asked how she lives without water or
light
she says there's water coming in through
the room
are believed to be romanchenko's remains
were taken to the local more ukraine's
foreign minister is calling his death an
unspeakable crime writing on twitter
romanchenko survived hitler
but was murdered by putin
mike armstrong global news cheshire
poland
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm jackson prosko we'll
leave you tonight with a call for help
said through strings
[Music]
ukrainian cellist dennis karachevsev
shared this video of himself playing to
the backdrop of harkev now in ruins he
says he hopes his performances encourage
more people to send aid to ukraine and
to help his city rebuild
thanks for watching and i hope you can
join us again tomorrow have a great
night